you probably need to
uh have multiple agents running in your
head
so one agent is how do i play
good chess yeah second agent how do i
play not too good of chess
and third agent is how do i help lex uh
move correctly correctly sure
okay we have five minutes each
uh looks like i've got you've given me
white legs which is nice of you uh we
will start the clock so my clock's
counting down
okay
non-standard yeah the english opening
you know i'm english so i have to do
that so you know you press the clock
when you're when you've done your move
that's a good starting move very solid
legs oh that's not good no this is good
this is very solid okay
we're quite far away from the uh
from the board
oh yeah yeah i'll press your clock for
you don't worry
all right
are we far away from the english opening
at this no this is a this is a good line
you're playing very um very standard
you have to get used to this
they always do the funny thing where uh
very nice pinning
you have to take notes of actually what
move your you've taken yes
uh
yeah that's a good always a good plan
keeping the king safe
i'm gonna do the same play very well so
far would you would you say yeah you
made it
no nothing so far this is i'm not gonna
here's the bishop night swap that we
were talking about earlier right the
tension you're creating the tension in
the creator
you're leaving the tension exactly
all right
now it gets harder now you have to come
up with your middle game plan
would you say you did a very good
opening
so you're
you're in a fine position so far yeah
very nice
very nice
what's your strongest opener opening
game or end game
i would say probably in the middle game
middle games at this kind of this kind
of point
very good very good very aggressive very
aggressive legs
if i could
sacrifice pieces you tried
that's not a good move isn't it that's a
good move that's a very nice move
um
are you afraid of using the queen ah
yeah the queen you know you've got to be
careful when you use the queen
i need to complicate the game a little
bit for you you're you're doing too well
like oh am i losing a piece here no
you're not losing a piece you're doing
okay actually
i'm going to take it anyway
it's only a pawn
how's those
that's how it starts but it's only a
porn
very good
this is not teleport i'm only a porn
star
i have to
uh
i don't feel comfortable with you having
a queen on the board
take the queens off that's dangerous it
makes me feel as much yeah so now we're
in the end game now so you're you're on
better territory what's the definition
of an end game well the queen's coming
off is usually the beginning of the end
game it's not the only um part of the
end game but it's it's one bit of the
end game see there's a pretty cool idea
what you've done there
i'll take off your night now i think the
internet is gonna disagree with that
now i'm gonna see this is interesting
dynamic position with your bishop and my
knight but my knight's in a good
good strong spot there ah so you're
attacking the bishop my my oh the bishop
is not so what do i do with this bishop
yeah maybe i should use some other kind
of way all right yeah uh
but then you're gonna attack there i
don't know
i think i'm just
running scared running scared fear can't
run
running
um
okay
yeah that's not is that oh that's okay
actually this is the only one
all right
it feels like there's not much to do
here well you gotta you have to have to
come at something good here
oh boy and the time's running out and
time's running out
escape that's a good escape for your
king i'm gonna come here now yeah
there's nothing else there's nothing
else i cannot get another one of your
pawns
i feel like there's some smart move that
i'm totally missing
yeah that seems reasonable but i'm not
going to tell you a second point
okay that's what you mean yeah
i'm going to go here
and you can just
eat away at the eat away at your stuff
all right
this is not this is slowly slowly
constricting you
yeah it's only going to take all your
pawns
you play very well though lex you
haven't made any major mistakes it's
just slow slow slow death the internet
honestly will very much disagree but um
let's see this a slow death is better
than than a fan of foster
embarrassing in the beginning we said i
didn't get checkmate in the first few
minutes exactly this feels very
constrained yeah you're very slowly
constrained i'm trying to play like
alpha zero um is that that would have
been a kind of controlled uh
controlled end
you know the interesting thing is the
willingness to sacrifice pieces by us
yes that's so beautiful it is beautiful
see so now i'm going to make use of all
these pawns i've taken
um
would you say your
alpha zero is much better than you at
sacrificing pieces oh yeah
intentionally i sometimes you know lose
them by mistake
but alpha zero is planning to lose them
it feels extremely constraining yeah how
close do you check me is there any way
for me out of this no really no so these
pieces can yeah i'm getting basically
all your pieces are getting constrained
i'm just going to march these pawns down
here or bring this rook to help out okay
so if i take this knight with the rock
yeah you could do that that would be a
final sort of um hope my night's you see
how strong my night's been in this game
compared to your bishop yeah as we were
talking about it
yeah it's done all the damage
yeah you can get rid of him now
but i think he's already it's really oh
and my time right now and your time
right now
but now i'm gonna get take advantage of
your background weakness
all right
and uh
right and then this pawn structure
you're gonna bring out the other yeah
i'm gonna bring the other finally gonna
swing the other rook into the game
check
and i'm just going to keep running okay
how many uh moves would you estimate
here uh it's going to be about 10 from
here
i'm going to swap your rook off
your final defensive piece i'm going to
take
is there's no that's that's fine well
you can i'll check you here
oh
yeah
and he's just marched there we're gonna
march his phone to the end now well i
think this is uh a good time
he played well honor uh to have been
defeated so gracefully he played very
very well i was impressed i was
impressed you you did you did great i
didn't ask you what do you think is the
most beautiful thing you've seen alpha
zero do oh yes personally yes so there
was actually
the most beautiful game that i've seen
alpha zero plays is being dubbed the
immortal zogswang game by
uh uh akadamata on the one of youtube
brilliant youtube uh commentators
uh
uh and he
it was alpha zero playing
and
sacrificing a load of pieces to
uh get stock fishes all of the
sockfish's major pieces queen and two
rooks stuck in the corner basically
sealed them up like in a tomb
and zugswang means
at that uh any move that the player
makes will make their position worse and
um it's never been done to stockfish
before and alpha zero did it super
elegantly through sacrificing
sacrificing pieces yeah it's a beautiful
video online on it and thank you for
giving me and signing this book
you're welcome uh what's what is the
book
the book was written by um the british
chess champion and uh and uh women
international master natasha reagan and
matthew sadler
and we gave i known them both for years
for my chest days as a kid and um
when they heard about alpha zero uh
before we released it they they they
wanted to come in and try it out we gave
them full behind-the-scenes access to it
and then um matthew sadler said to me
it's like discovering the notebooks of a
of a of a hidden champion that no one
knew about and he then wrote this book
about all of the different ideas that
alpha zero had and the cool thing is in
there in that book so this is it's a
chess book but also the first few
chapters about about how we built alpha
zero our journey towards it and then
magnus carlsen was one of the first
people we gave the book to
and he uh
he sort of probably said it was very
useful to him and he's incorporated a
lot of the ideas into his own play the
new ideas you could say created by alpha
alpha zero to lex a fellow explorer of
the mysteries of the universe
thomas that thank you so much thank you
for everything you do